NOW THAT YOU THINK ABOUT IT, IT
IS ALMOST THAT HE WILL NEVER BE
PRESIDENT BAIRD BEN SHAPIRO HOST
ONE OF AMERICA'S TOP PODCAST
"THE BEN SHAPIRO SHOW," THE
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK "THE RIGHT
SIDE OF HISTORY," AND WERE HAPPY
TO HAVE HIM ON SITE TONIGHT.
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW I KEPT A
STRAIGHT FACE WHILE YOU DID THA
THAT.
>> Tucker: THERE ARE SO MANY
LEVELS HERE, BUT I DO BELIEVE
THIS IS THE END OF THE BETO
O'ROURKE PHENOMENON.
>> YEAH, I THINK HE IS TOAST.
>> Tucker: WHAT LESSON SHOULD
WE DRAW FROM WHAT WE JUST SAW?
>> YOU CAN RUN IN THE MODERATELY
AS BOBBY KENNEDY CANDIDATE SO
LONG AS NOTHING NEWER IS ON THE
BLOCK.
BUTTIGIEG CAME ALONG AND HAD
INTERSECTIONAL CREDIBILITY.
THE PROBLEM FOR BETO HAD THE
PROBLEM BEING STRAIGHT AND ALSO
WHITE.
BUTTIGIEG IS GAY AND TAKES
PRECEDENCE, AND SPEAKS MORE
LANGUAGES, INCLUDING NORWEGIAN,
AND HE DOESN'T JUST PLAY GUITAR,
HE PLAYS PIANO AND DOES IT WITH
THE WHOLE DEAL.
BUTTIGIEG HAS BASICALLY STOLEN
ALL OF HIS MOMENTUM, THEY THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT, I THINK BETO IS
TOAST HERE.
>> Tucker: SPEAKING NORWEGIAN
AND PLAYING THE PIANO.
I'M BEING SINCERE, ACTUALLY
IMPRESSIVE.
I'M IMPRESSED BY THEM.
BUT THEY ARE NOT REALLY POLICY
PRESCRIPTIONS, THEY ARE NOT
IDEAS THAT ARE GOING TO IMPROVE
AMERICA.
AND NEITHER IS WHO YOU SLEEP
WITH RELEVANT TO RUNNING THE
COUNTRY SO FAR AS I CAN TELL, OR
ANY OF THESE CRITERIA
MEANINGFUL.
WHERE'S THE PART WHERE WE GET TO
DEBATE THEIR IDEAS FOR THE
COUNTRY?
>> THE PROBLEM IS OBVIOUSLY THAT
THERE IS ONLY ONE THOUGHT LEADER
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY RIGHT
NOW, AND THAT IS BERNIE SANDERS
BAIRD WHAT YOU ARE SEEING IS A
BUNCH OF CANDIDATES WERE
ATTEMPTING TO STEER INTO THE
BERNIE SANDERS LANE.
THERE IS NO ROOM IN THAT LANE,
BERNIE SANDERS HAS OCCUPIED THAT
ENTIRE LANE.
YOU TALK ABOUT CANDIDATES, THE
ONE WHO KEEPS SHOUTING IDEAS
FROM THE ROOFTOPS IS ON
NATIVE AMERICAN CANDIDATE,
ELIZABETH WARREN, WHO KEEPS
SPOUTING IDEAS EVERY 5 MINUTES.
HERE IS A NEW POLICY
PRESCRIPTION, WHY IS IT ANYONE
PAYING ATTENTION TO ME?
THE ANSWER IS BECAUSE YOU ARE IN
BERNIE SANDERS' LANE.
IN THE MODERATE LANE, THERE ARE
NO THOUGHT LEADERS, THEY ARE
JUST A BUNCH OF PEOPLE WITH
PLATITUDES.
BIDEN IS PRESUMABLY BE THOUGHT
LEADER, BUT HE DOESN'T HAVE
ENOUGH THOUGHTS TO BE A THOUGHT
LEADER, SO WHO EXACTLY IS GOING
TO COME ALONG AND OCCUPY THAT
LANE WHILE STILL BEING ABLE TO
WIN OVER THE WOKE INTERSECTIONAL
BASE OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
WHOEVER DOES THAT HAS A
POSSIBILITY A NOMINATION CAN
RIGHT NOW, BUTTIGIEG CAN DO THAT
ONLY INSOFAR AS HE CAN SPEAK
PLATITUDES THAT SOUND MODERATE,
BUT WHEN HE HAS PEGGED DOWN, AS
YOU NOTED, HE IS JUST AS FAR
LEFT AS BERNIE SANDERS.
>> Tucker: TELLING US WHAT A
GREAT CHRISTIAN HE IS, ABORTION
UP UNTIL BIRTH, SPARE ME YOUR
CHRISTIAN TALK, PLEASE.
IT IS ABSURD.
I'M STRUCK BY BERNIE COULD BE
THE ONE GUY -- I WANT TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT IDEAS,
BECAUSE I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT,
AND CLEARLY WE NEED TO MAKE
CHANGES THE WAY THE COUNTRY IS
GOING, BUT BERNIE DOESN'T SEEM
TO BE AN IDEAS CANDIDATE WHEN
YOU LISTEN TO HIM, HE ALMOST
NEVER SAYS ANYTHING INTERESTING,
WHY IS THAT?
>> HIS IDEAS ARE SO RADICAL, BUT
THEY ARE CONSISTENT.
SO EVERYONE HAS FOLLOWED HIM OUT
TO THE RANGE.
MEDICARE FOR ALL, WHAT YOU WILL
SEE IS EVERY DEMOCRAT PAY HOMAGE
TO MEDICARE FOR ALL, FOOTNOTE,
WE DON'T REALLY WANT MEDICARE
FOR ALL, WANT A GRADUAL PLAN TO
ACHIEVE MEDICARE FOR ALL
SOMETIME IN THE FUTURE.
EVERYONE IS TRYING TO IMITATE
BERNIE.
BERNIE IS THE GUY WHO IS RUNNING
THIS RACE.
HE IS ANY POSITION RIGHT NOW
THAT TRUMP WAS IN A 2016,
EVERYBODY IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS RUNNING I'M
AFRAID TO TAKE HIM OFF BECAUSE
THEY HOPE HE EVENTUALLY WILL
COLLAPSE AND THEY WILL GET HIS
SUPPORT, BUT HE IS WRITING 25 TO
30% IN ALL THE POLLS, START NEAL
30% IN ALL THE POLLS, START NEAY
30% IN ALL THE POLLS, START NEAD
30% IN ALL THE POLLS, START NEAR
30% IN ALL THE POLLS, START NEAB
30% IN ALL THE POLLS, START NEAE
30% IN ALL THE POLLS, START NEA.
HE CAN SPEAK DURING THAT LANE,
WIN IOWA, NEW HAMPSHIRE, TO
WELCOME IN CALIFORNIA AND
NEW YORK CARE THERE'S A REASON
DEMOCRATS ARE RUNNING SCARED OF
BERNIE, WHAT IS PUZZLING TO ME H
BERNIE, WHAT IS PUZZLING TO ME O
INTERESTED IN WHAT THE
JOURNALISTS ON TWITTER SAY, THIS
ECHO CHAMBER IN THE MEDIA, THAT
THEY WON'T JUST GO TO WHERE THE
MAINSTREAM OF THEIR OWN PARTY
IS, WHICH IS THE MODERATE AREA.
JOE BIDEN IS A TERRIBLE
CANDIDATE, HE IS ACTUALLY
LEADING AND MOST OF THE POLLS
BECAUSE HE IS PERCEIVED AS A
MODERATE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S TOTALLY
TRUE!
>> BETO AND BUTTIGIEG, THE
REASON BOTH REDOING WELL FOR A
MOMENT WAS BECAUSE THEY WERE
BOTH PERCEIVED AS MODERATE     M
BOTH PERCEIVED AS MODERATE     D
BOTH PERCEIVED AS MODERATE     R
BOTH PERCEIVED AS MODERATE     T
BOTH PERCEIVED AS MODERATE     E
BOTH PERCEIVED AS MODERATE     W
BOTH PERCEIVED AS MODERATE     T
BOTH PERCEIVED AS MODERATE     H
ALL OF THE PLATITUDES.
THEY WANT TO BE MORE LIKE BERNIE
THAN BIDEN, NOBODY IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS THE STONES
TO RUN AS A MODERATE INSIDE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, EVEN THOUGH IT
IS PROBABLY THE BEST POSSIBLE
WAY FOR THEM TO WIN THE
NOMINATION.
>> Tucker: I THINK YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, AND HER
DIAGNOSIS IS THAT THEY ARE
CAPTIVE OF SOCIAL MEDIA.
>> I THINK THERE ARE CAPTIVE TO
SOCIAL MEDIA, THE
INTERSECTIONAL, WOKE BASE AFRAID
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO BE HELD
HOSTAGE TO THE DICTATES OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" EDITORIAL
BOARD, PEOPLE SUGGESTING THEY
ARE NOT WOKE ENOUGH IF THEY
DON'T PAY HOMAGE TO THE LATEST
FLAVOR, SLAVERY REPARATIONS OR
WHATEVER IT IS TODAY.
>> Tucker: THE PERSON WHO
GIVES THE FINGER TO THAT MOM
GETS THE SUPPORT OF MILLIONS.
>> I THINK THAT IS RIGHT, AND
HAS A GOOD SHOT IN THE GENERAL.
BUT I DON'T THINK ANY OF THEM --
>> Tucker: GET MY SUPPORT.
>> SOMEONE WOULD STAND UP AND
SAY I WILL TAKE ORDERS FROM YOU,
HOW ABOUT SOME?
DON'T EVEN CARE WHAT THEY ARE
FAIR, I WOULD VOTE FOR THEM
PEERED SO DESPERATE FOR THAT.
>> THAT IS WHY THEY DEMOCRAT
WERE ABLE TO DO THAT, THEY WOULD
WIN SWEEPING SUPPORT.
BUT I CAN'T DO THAT.
WE HAVE BEEN SAYING THIS FOR